de los atentados del 13 de noviembre del
2015 en parís la luz va a todas partes
con su equipo de primeros auxilios en la
espalda
antiguo fisioterapeuta dejó su carrera
yo también me protejo y hoy es un
socorrista profesional
sanz es mi
objetivo
esto es para que los transeúntes y la
policía puedan ver quién soy y me
permitan ayudar
acs lo que tengo que hacer esto es algo
que desarrollé basado en el primer kit o
utilizado por la policía élite francesa
lage y gm
puedo ponerlo en mi cuello entonces uso
el kit
este no está en el suelo todo permanece
adentro y a mano cuando lo necesito
djelic vive justo encima del bar label y
keep en este lugar 19 personas murieron
cuando los atacantes abrieron fuego
el asalto duró cuatro largos minutos
tan pronto se fueron la luz se apresuró
a ayudar a los heridos
vi a una mujer joven con una herida en
el muslo sangrando de forma abundante
fue una lesión arterial se necesitaba
una acción inmediata me quité el
cinturón lo envolví dos veces y lo
apreté lo más que pude tuve que detener
la hemorragia no podía quedarme con una
sola persona había muchos heridos
alrededor mido me volteé y había una
segunda víctima este estaba con una
lesión en el abdomen
desde esa noche la luz no puede evitar
pensar en que quizás pudo salvar más
vidas con este ex bombero ofrece
informaciones en primeros auxilios a
quien lo solicite
estuvo de 27 minutos y durante ese
tiempo la gente moría a mi alrededor es
necesario reflexionar más sobre este
tema particularmente en francia
porque no es suficiente apoyarse sólo en
el cuerpo oficial de socorro
djelic aún lucha para poder vivir con el
recuerdo de lo que vio también ha
presentado una demanda civil en el
juicio por los atentados